neil de saddam touraine la parole le cas
monsieur dino cinieri
merci il se présente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
j'associe à ma question lors invoquer
yves nicolin paul salen et l'ensemble de
mes collègues des républicains le 8 et 9
octobre dernier l'association nationale
dès maires ruraux de france s'est réuni
en congrès à saint vincent de bois c'est
dans la loire monsieur le premier
ministre la colère gronde dans nos
campagnes après le redécoupage
dévastateur de nos territoires par la
loi notre après la laborieuse réforme
des rythmes scolaires après l'historique
baisse des dotations de l'état pour les
collectivités locales voici le projet de
loi de finances 2010 est qui inquiète
fortement nos élus locaux les maires
ruraux exercent leur mandat avec
beaucoup de sérieux et de bon sens mais
aujourd'hui ils ont besoin d'une bouffée
d'oxygène pour une meilleure lisibilité
budgétaire chaque investissement
nécessite une réflexion concertée et
résonner dans l'intérêt d'un
développement économique et de la
création d'emplois chaque jour les
maires ruraux lutte sans relâche pour
réduire les fractures territoriales
il appelle à une ruralité plus vivante
car la ruralité c'est un véritable
poumon vert indispensable à l'équilibré
de notre nation
monsieur le premier ministre la
république c'est l'égalité entre tous
les citoyens
l'égalité c'est d'avoir le choix d'un
médecin l'égalité c'est d'avoir les
mêmes chances de réussite scolaire
l'égalité c'est de disposer des mêmes
moyens de communication l'égalité c'est
de matières haussier les chaînes
publiques de proximité comme les
trésoreries locale oui monsieur le
premier ministre un habitant en zone
rurale peut aussi ses impôts attend la
même éducation pour ses enfants et à la
même qualité de vie qu'en zone urbaine
ne nous estimer pas de richesse des
territoires ruraux trop souvent oublié
ma question et doom sur le premier
ministre pourquoi renoncez vous à mettre
en oeuvre dès 2017 la réforme de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement tant
attendu par les collectivés locales et
si les tables merde il a pas l'air
monsieur jean michel baylet ministre de
l'aménagement du territoire de la
ruralité et des collectivités
territoriales
merci monsieur prêt à monsieur le député
dino cinieri vous savez nous sommes en
ce moment même dans le débat sur la
montagne nous y participer activement la
ruralité est une priorité pour le
gouvernement et nous le démontrons au
travers de trois comités
interministériels ruralité qui se sont
tenues en 14 mois
rien n'avait été fait depuis 2010
104 mesures ont été arrêtées et non des
moindres comme l'instauration d'un
contrat de ruralité qui sont le pendant
des contrats de ville madame la ministre
de la santé et des affaires sociales
vient de vous répondre sur les maisons
vient de répondre à votre collègue sur
les dons de santé nous allons aussi
créer dans la ruralité des maisons de
services au public
mille lanternes seront opérationnels à
la fin de l'année c'est le grand retour
de service public dans la rivalité nous
sommes entrés et nous allons avons
débattu hier soir et de l'encore débat
de ce soir nous sommes en train de
mettre en place le plan très haut débit
doté de 20 milliards d'euros dont 3
milliards payés par l'état nous avons
fait tous les efforts nécessaires pour
la ruralité et je vous renvoie aux
annonces du présent la république lors
du congrès des maires qui a divisé par
deux les forts du bloc communal c'est à
dire 1 milliards au lieu de deux pour le
redressement des finances publiques qui
a augmenté le pain spécial
d'investissement de 1 milliard un
milliard deux pour un compas
d'investissement collectivités et qui a
surtout augmenté encore de terre pour
l'apporter meilleure dotation
d'équipement des titans viraux elles
augmenté de 62% en trois ans jamais de
tels efforts n'avaient été faits pour la
réalité enfin monsieur le député vous
interroger sur la réponse de la dgm il
faut que vous sachiez que lorsque j'ai
reçu en sommes bien sûr version d'élus
lors de ma nomination pour parler le
répondeur dgf ils m'ont remis à
l'unanimité une motion demandant le
report